can you just talk to us a little bit
about you know the typical iceland
shopper and how difficult they're
finding things now
well the reality is there is no uh
typical icing shopper averages don't
work very well because we have people
who come in and spend five quid and
people who come in and spend 50 quid um
but yeah generally i think it's safe to
say that everyone is is feeling the
pinch now doesn't matter who you are and
now we we do serve um some of the poorer
demographics around the country and we
are hearing stories as you said of some
um some of our custom disappearing to
food banks which is a reality or indeed
some customers um when they're at the
till asking the cashier when it amounts
to 40 quid so that they can leave the
rest of their shopping um we're seeing
uh people trading to the best value um
packs and and products um so yeah i
think it's it's fair to say that
everyone's feeling the pinch but
certainly the harder press communities
are feeling it more than anyone
yeah it really does take a picture of
just how difficult so many people are
finding it and of course inflation a big
concern over the board but grocery price
uh inflation uh in particular a real
worry as they hit a 13-year high um can
you just give us a bit of a sense about
what specific foods so
arising by and how much
yeah um again it's you know there's
there's no one particular metric what's
interesting about that food inflation
figure um the median kind of food
inflation figure of seven eight percent
um it includes things like champagne and
legs of lamb um now some of our
customers certainly aren't buying that
and um the reality is that you know the
basic staples are increasing more we've
seen as you'll know loaf of bread which
is now 1 pound 10 it probably was about
89 p
milk
across all retailers has has gone up
quite dramatically it's across the board
and that's because there's a perfect
kind of maelstrom of inflationary
pressures from commodity um price
increases
through to labor shortages in in the
fields and factories um through to the
price of fuel to uh to move goods around
uh through to genuine supply shortages
like um
sunflower oil
or wheat and both of which come from
ukraine and for obvious reasons you know
both of those uh things have have dried
up and the unintended consequences of
that it's not just a bottle of sunflower
oil or the wheat in your bread um
sunflower oil finds its way as a
vegetable fat into hundreds of different
ready meals and pre-prepared meals
and wheat goes into animal feed so that
is having a knock-on consequence of the
price of everything from bacon to
chicken
it's interesting talking about ukraine
and the prime minister and president
zolensky spoke just a couple of days ago
about the impact of the blockage of the
port of odessa and the supply of of
grain around the world
and
just looking forward how concerned are
you about the impact that this could
have and how much do you think food
could actually go up by in the months
ahead
look um you know
there's people far cleverer than me who
are forecasting this stuff um i think
it's impossible to say i think from
where we are at the moment i'm not
gravely concerned around supply issues
uh i and i think if you look at our own
business we are especially resilient as
a frozen
first retailer um we we can build up
stocks we have uh long uh supply lines
which um which we've been working on two
years worth of shelf life so we're we're
very resilient and as a private family
business we can invest in the right
places for our customers and that's why
we're doing a ton of different offers
and deals and promotions and value
packages just to try and help through
our customers
last week for example on tuesday we ran
our first over 60s discount of 10
which was unbelievably well received um
by our um some of our customers and
we've held the price of all of our one
pound lines to the end of the year
that's a major investment by us because
the price the cost of those goods have
gone up so we're making no money on
those now but we think it's the right
thing to do
and we've reduced the threshold of our
home delivery because that service is
more important than ever for people who
can't afford to drive into town centers
and spend the money on fuel
and rather to take their free home
delivery service so there's loads of
different things that we can do it's
certainly not going to get any easier i
don't know how how much worse it's going
to get um but hopefully
ourselves and our competitors are
resilient enough to to get through it
for our customers
yeah certainly some concerning times
ahead the government unveiled its big
support package
this week to help families is there
anything specifically that you would
like to see the government do going
forward to try and help tackle you know
the rising cost of food
do you know what i must say you know i
think the government the chancellor in
particular has um
has really uh stepped up and and
you know pulled the right levers
they already had over 20 billion pounds
of support before this additional 20
billion pounds of latest packages so
certainly huge intervention there by the
government and actually we've got to
take a step back and realize that you
know a lot of these pressures are global
in nature and um a lot of these
pressures are outside of uh the
influence of of the government of the
day or businesses like ours so i think
they've they've they've done plenty
actually for the general public and
hopefully it will ease the pain and the
burden as we get into the autumn as as
um inflation may peak and there's a ton
of stuff i'd like him to do for business
um i don't know how he's going to
afford it um or we're all going to pay
for it um but i think at the moment
they're doing a good job